all right we're still here in miami site
of super bowl 54 and it's weird
to be at the super bowl at radio radio
room be able to talk to patriots players
you guys usually off limits you're
sequestered this year you're not
sequestered something's not right the
world's not right when the patriots are
available it's devin and jason mccordy i
got that right devin and jason mccourty
twins the only way you can tell them
apart is the facial hair that's it
everything else is the same joining me
here uh on behalf of pizza hut how's it
going guys it's been fun man having a
lot of fun today yeah and uh it really
is weird to not have the patriots in the
super bowl i mean we're just so used to
it every year the patriots are here
every year and i know the one year a few
years ago with the broncos they weren't
but it's it's
what's the biggest difference for you
guys this week doing stuff like this
like uh
talking about and it's kind of like hey
if you guys don't go to a super bowl and
it's like that every year and i'm like
well we plan to be in the super bowl but
now getting a chance to partner up with
pizza and then to do something that's
very twin-esque like
pizza hut's giving away two tickets to
super bowl 51 55 55 yeah free pizza for
two years and you get 22 000 if you have
twins after kickoff on this sunday so
the first folks who have twins after
kickoff if they do if they do what jay's
about to tell them they have an
opportunity to win all of this like he
said twins after kickoff you go on
twitter post a picture of the twins with
the date and time at pizza hut on your
post all you have to do is hashtag ph
twin to win and hashtag promotion and
you enter a chance to get all of that
fun stuff that dad talked about so
there's gonna be a couple somewhere
that is holding on right as long as they
can oh nope the contractions honey
they're not that far apart just hold on
a little bit let's talk about it earlier
it's gonna be a father-like babe
order the pizza hut get the official
sponsor order the pizza get you some
meat lovers some wings and have it
create a good a good aurora yes and and
then as soon as the game starts it goes
from hold on hold on to push push push
porsche we need to watch the game yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly that's a great
promotion pizza hut's been a big part of
the nfl we love pizza i love you i got
to get these shirts
so far we got about three or four
different requests that we're going to
have to get those shirts out it's
awesome
it is awesome and uh pizza hut is
awesome pizza and it's great to have you
guys here so um
let's focus on one of the guys that
we've all been trying to figure out how
in the world the san francisco 49ers are
going to stop him obviously patrick
mahomes you guys have seen you guys had
to deal with them what's the key to
trying to contain a guy like patrick
mahomes i think one of the things that
when we did have success was getting
pressure on them whether
it was with four or we sent five guys
but it was getting pressure to him
i wanna pretty much immediately like
getting someone in his face making him
roll out when he doesn't want to like
creating that type of atmosphere and
he's still gonna make some plays like
you're never gonna like just handicap
him he's still gonna make some plays but
to me that is the way that you kind of
have some control like last year ac
championship held him with zero points
in the first half this year the second
half held on to three points the other
half of those games he was patrick
mahomes but yeah those were the things
we did well we're not happy it really is
amazing how when he finds the gas pedal
you never know when he's going to do it
but all of a sudden he's going to just
like they're down 10 points to tennessee
and boom it's 21-17 at the half just
like that it happens so fast it's like
you can't stop it you can't you can't
just sit back and zone because he's too
good of a quarterback and he'll be able
to pick it apart but the issue is when
you say hey we're just gonna man these
guys up the next thing you know it's a
60 yard bomb and tiger hill mccall
mccarthy they're catching these long so
it's just that you have to find and even
meet him like he said of being able to
get pressure and not giving up the big
play or being able to keep yourself in
the game and obviously i think this
matchup is so fun because san francisco
can run the ball so if they're able to
run the ball effectively and keep him
off the field it's huge well and
wouldn't that be the belichick approach
to mahomes in a game like this with all
this riding on it have long possessions
offensively
chew up the clock take the full 40
seconds have long long drives frustrate
their offense they're standing on the
sideline watching and then when he's on
the field he's going to press a little
bit more and take
back off and just force him to be
patient and work his way down the field
i've heard bill say before
you can't win a game and play good
defense banking on your offense to have
good drives so like he always talked
about putting a plan together and like i
know one of the key things when we
played kansas city was
making them like you just said not
always backing up but making them drive
the like have four third down
conversions not just giving up like the
times that they've had great success on
us they've had probably five to six
plays over 40 to 50 yards it feels like
they thrive on that yeah and i assume
that that takes
away some of your heart as well when you
give up a big play like that yeah it's a
pendulum swing yeah definitely and
especially depending upon what situation
in the game you give up a third and
short long touchdown like we did last
year and we played in the first time in
new england and that's just not the team
you want to get in the shootout with so
i think like you just said when you give
up those long plays even watching the
tennessee game tennessee was playing
tough trying to mount a comeback and
then next you know the ball goes over
your head and it's just such it's such a
deflating play to the defense what's
gonna happen for you guys to not be
available next year on behalf of pizza
hut so you'll be at practice today
instead what's gotta go on
well i gotta pick a team i gotta see how
that works out yeah agency um
but you know you want to stay with the
patriots though for me right right now i
have to see how it works out you know
like i would not like i don't like not
want to be in new england but i think
once you're a 10-year vet like
it's not the same as when you're younger
and you're you know the cornerstone of a
team or like a key freak like you got to
kind of see what's best for you and your
family and go from there
okay assuming that you you will be with
the patriots what do the patriots have
to do to get back uh first i guess they
have to pick up my team option for me to
be back um but i'm not sure i think
that's what bill does such a great job
of year and year round and obviously
this year with uh tom brady being a free
agent that's the biggest question mark
that they've had in a long time so i
think that's probably the number one
thing that you have to dictate from
there and then uh like dev always used
to tell me when you're a good team and
you have good players it's very hard to
keep them all under wraps so guys like
devin mccourty guys like kyle van noy
jamie collins joe tooney like all of
those guys are free agents and uh it
makes it tough to keep it going but i
think once all of that passes free
agency to draft now it's about x's and
o's and figuring out you know what i
mean how are we going to keep this
defense playing at a high level what
else do we need on offense to give brady
or whoever exactly what we need to get
to the next level those will be the
things where obviously you look at we
fell short this year key phrase or
whoever i mean tom brady one of the
highest profile free agents in the
history of the nfl if he chooses to
change teams do you guys have any
inclination any lean any thought as to
what he's going to do no i have no idea
no idea and i think for him he probably
doesn't have much of an idea you know
like for us especially for like we just
talked about for three or four years
straight we've just played so much
football that we never really get true
downtime so i think guys have spent a
lot of time i think for him like you
just said family family is very
important that's kind of why we got
involved with pizza they were two
brothers that started the company
together and i think for tom right now
that's probably the most important thing
for him right now he's probably just
with his family and whatever move he
makes next is gonna be in the best
interest of him and his family and that
very well may be to stay right there
annoying i mean from the outside
it feels like the time has come for him
to move on i don't know what it feels
like it's just a feeling just to where
it's how it's even gotten to this point
like it wouldn't get to this point if he
was staying there'd already be a deal in
place to keep him around the fact that
we're six weeks away from free agency it
just makes me feel like he's gonna go
somewhere else and that's what's weird i
think there's two type of feelings like
you just said i think that makes a lot
of sense for people and then there's
other people like well if you do
something for 20 years someplace why
would you ever leave so you just never
know but like you said it's up in the
air tyree kill's got to be one of the
fastest guys in the nfl right now what
what is it like when
he is at full speed and you are out
there trying to just stay within
shouting he is the fastest player i've
ever played against and i don't know if
other people are close but he is by far
the fastest to go from zero to top speed
like a crossing route a bubble screen
like he catches it he takes one step and
you're like like how like how did some
guys need to take a few steps to get the
top speed he's instantly there i think
the difference is you've played against
some receivers that straight line are
just they're fast we're just like but it
was just like hey he's either running a
goal or he's running a stop and i think
with tyreke hill he has the agility and
his quickness to go side to side and
then get vertical extremely fast so i
think the combination of that and then
you've just seen how much he's developed
as a receiver since he's been in the
league that makes when you can run fast
you're tough to cover it's that simple
well guys it's been great talking to you
and great partnership with pizza hut
great promotion give everybody again
what they need to do to be eligible for
the the uh super bowl 55 tickets and
everything else that goes along with it
yeah you have a chance to win tickets
the subal 55 two years of free pizza and
22 thousand dollars to your future twins
college fund yeah post a picture on
twitter after the kids are born date and
time uh ph twin to win hashtag that
hashtag promotion pizza hut and then
also if you're not having twins but
you're you're looking for something
follow pizza on super bowl sunday and
they're going to have different prompts
and stuff going on and all you have to
do is uh hashtag hut sweeps and hashtag
promotion and there'll be other cool
things he may end up at the dragons
i'm excited to see who gets the the
prize and who pops out the twins yeah
right after kickoff he'll be the real
mvp devon and jason mccourty thanks to
you guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports